wer bei shanghai
jeder tag ist
sind wir mal wieder alles neu beginnt
grusel stunde mit 16 wir sind heute auf
geisterjagd team ist neben mir und wir
haben experten in sachen grusel geister
und mordgeschichten den christopher
machen uns angst bitte zunächst einmal
wir stehen hier an der frauenkirche und
wie man sehen kann die frauenkirche ist
ringsum bestückt mit grabsteine
das nicht umsonst denn wo wir hier
stehen das war früher mal einen friedhof
anfang des 19 jahrhunderts da war ein
friedhof wie heute ja auch ein eher
unheimlicher ort es gab mal einen
kaufmann der ist über den friedhof
gegangen
tatsächlich hat er auf einem der
grabsteine eine weiße gestalt gesehen da
hat er sich zunächst mal gewonnen es
mehr gegangen und zum vorschein kam ein
grinsender totenschädel
er rannte sie sich nach hause und öffnet
ist eine schlafkammer wollte sich gerade
hier liegen stellte fest er hatte das
fenster aufgelassen und schon hörte ja
dass die skelette hand über den
fenstersims griff und gott sei dank hat
er über seinem bett
das bild der mutter gott ist das griff
er schleuderte es nach dem geist und
gegen die mutter gottes hatte der geist
natürlich keine chance er löste sich in
luft auf und war damit verschwunden
dann schauen wir mal ganz kurz in diese
kirche rein
das ist die dreifaltigkeitskirche und da
gibt es viele merkwürdige details in
dieser kirche unter anderem dort oben
dieses symbol mit den drei ineinander
verwobenen kreisen und abrisses
abmessungen wo card ein abgrund ruf den
nächsten
das heißt so viel wie ein unglück das
nächste nach sich
an dieser stelle stand der jungen
phantom der war teil der zweiten
startnummer befestigung von münchen dass
der letzte klägliche rest der übrig
geblieben ist jung vom turm heißt da war
hier soll eine eiserne jungfrau
gestanden haben
das ist ein mittelalterliches
folterinstrument und hier kann die
schweiz
hier kann ich schreie aus
nach all diesen gruseligen geschichten
und wird zeit für was positives hier
eine portion glück denn wenn man an die
der nase reibt holt man sich glück alte
münchner brauch bitte darum noch soviel
schauergeschichten ist das mal ganz gut
für die seele
christopher ich danke dir vielmals für
diese große geschichten ich hoffe ich
kann heute nacht gut schlafen und in dem
sinne